[Music]
recently for the daily cancellation we
spent some time
dumping on boomers after jeff foxworthy
tried to blame the younger generations
for the existence of participation
trophies and as i pointed out the
boomers label millennials the
participation trophy generation
are neglecting to mention that they the
boomers are the ones who invented
participation trophies and gave them out
in fact the boomers invented almost all
of the terrible things that are ripping
our society apart things like veganism
the internet
the sexual revolution
i don't know if boomer's actually
invented veganism but i'm blaming him
for it anyway but today we're gonna
we're gonna take the always enjoyable
generational blame game and move it over
to the younger set this time gen z and
millennials my generation technically
though from a spiritual and emotional
perspective i'm really more of a
disgruntled 85 year old hermit who lives
in a hollowed-out tree in the woods or
something i don't really identify with
my generation and this yahoo news
article reminds me why here's a headline
gen z and millennials are disrupting the
workplace as they're choosing to be
jobless rather than work for a company
they don't like
now there are different ways to be a
disrupter you could be the elon musk
type of disrupter doing new and bold
things
challenging the powerful institutions
innovating
or you could be the kind of disruptor
who disrupts by standing off to the side
like a useless lump and scratching your
ass while everyone else gets the work
done
sadly many of my peer group and younger
have chosen the latter course
so the article says quote gen z and
millennials are unique when it comes to
demanding a work-life balance they don't
just want flexible work hours and
environments they want to work for
companies that align with their own
personal beliefs and values and almost
half of gen z millennials would rather
be unemployed than unhappy in a job
according to a new study the career
goals of gen z and millennials are
changing power dynamics in the workplace
almost two and four members of younger
generations would prefer being
unemployed then work in a job they don't
like according to the study most of the
young people surveyed said they
preferred to work at companies that
shared their personal values
two and five gen zers and millennials
said they they would take a lower paying
salary if it meant that they were
purposefully contributing to society
diversity and inclusion were also
important to the survey respondents
forty nine percent of gianzine 46 of
millennials said that they wouldn't work
for a company that didn't make diversity
a priority
uh priority of gen z millennials is
their own happiness in fact 56 percent
of gen z and 55 millennials said they
would quit a job if it interfered with
our personal lives
now there's obviously nothing wrong with
wanting to work for a company that
represents your values i mean in
principle that's a very good thing the
problem is in the perverse and stupid
value system that so many of these
people want companies to align with as
evidenced by their insistence on
diversity and inclusion
um
aside from value alignment
we're also told that millennials in gen
z demand a better work-life balance that
they would rather be unemployed than
unhappy at their jobs and this this is
where the real problems arise i think
first of all
if you're a young person today or even
an old person
the balance you should be worried about
is not work life but screen life
we're told that young people don't want
to work don't want work to interfere
with their personal lives
but almost every waking hour of their
personal lives are wasted staring at
screens anyway
i could have more respect for the desire
for work-life balance if you were going
to home to be you know with your spouse
and children or you were
trying to leave yourself time to engage
in a productive hobby like woodworking
or gardening or something
but the fact is that for many of these
people the lives they're trying to
protect from workplace intrusion
are hardly lives at all
there's something quite morbidly ironic
about a man screaming that there's more
to his life than being a wage slave
only to discover that the only thing he
wants to do is scroll through tick-tock
and binge netflix
second even leaving that issue to the
side
the more fundamental problem with the
work life balance idea is that work and
life
are not two separate things
life is work it's a symptom of our
privilege and entitlement in the modern
industrialized west that we can even
consider life and work as two distinct
categories talk to anybody outside of
that bubble about their work-life
balance and they'll have no idea what
you're even talking about
because life requires work every life is
sustained by work
so when the self-righteous millennial or
gen zier turns up his nose and says i'd
rather be unemployed than unhappy
working
the question is then
who
will be doing the work to sustain his
existence
whether you're happy or not the fact of
life is that your life requires work and
if you refuse to do it somebody else has
to so who's that going to be your
parents
johnny taxpayer next door
maybe a combination whoever it is if
you you are not you are not living a
life free of the work requirement nobody
can
you are rather living a life where that
requirement has been offloaded to
somebody else
you've made someone else your slave in
effect you don't want to be a wage slave
so someone else is going to be your safe
there's nothing nothing noble about that
it's entitled it's selfish in fact it's
evil
the refusal to participate in the
difficult aspects of your own life
is evil
it's a shameful thing
third point we hear that um
all of these younger people are
prioritizing their happiness focusing on
their happiness
giving up work for the sake of happiness
pursuing happiness thinking about their
happiness talking about happiness
obsessing over their happiness and yet
shockingly
so few of them are actually happy
there have never been people who who
talk so much about happiness and yet
feel it so so little
isn't that interesting
millennials in gen z are are at once the
most focused on their happiness and and
yet also the least happy
perhaps there's a lesson there which we
might consider finally learning at some
point
and the lesson is that happiness cannot
be conjured out of the ether like a
magical spell
you can't will yourself into it you
can't convince yourself to be it
happiness is a byproduct of a
well-ordered well-situated grounded
virtuous productive life
that's the only way to achieve sustained
happiness
you can find pleasure outside of that
you can you know go to a back alley
somewhere buy some black tar heroin and
find some pleasure that way i guess you
could derive pleasure from an
extra-large
fast food value meal or a three dollar
hooker
but you won't find happiness any of
those places
and you won't find it in a directionless
life free of work free of challenge
spent staring at screens while somebody
else provides for all of your many needs
as it turns out life and work cannot be
severed and neither can happiness and
work
it takes work to be happy you have to do
difficult things you have to exert
yourself you have to
give yourself over to some cause beyond
yourself
happiness comes then as a side effect
often when you least expect it
and always when you aren't thinking
about it
you simply fulfill your responsibilities
you live your life you do your work
and one day you look up and you say wow
look at that i'm i'm happy
that's how happiness works
you only find it when you stop looking
for it
this is one of the fundamental facts of
life and it's something that both the
gen z and millennial generations would
do well to learn until then
they are
of course cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content